i think one of the things that concerns
me about the remote control
contraceptive chip that they're talking
about is that it's always on so if a
woman gets it in her body at the age of
14 it's always on and the remote control
turns it off but if the remote control
malfunctions she's it's always on and
she can no longer have kids women who's
controlling the remote control like what
percentage of women are being medicated
with hormonal treatments at a young age
already huge like a large number huge
yes and we're start you're starting now
to by the way see the pushback against
this because people are talking about
the absolutely horrific side effects of
birth control and what it does to women
um
i mean
it used to be a punch line hillary
clinton attacked um breitbart for
talking about this during the during the
election but and i think they were just
a little bit ahead of the curve and not
everybody's talking about this yeah you
used to think birth control whatever now
it's like i respect a woman that doesn't
want to use it yeah
i i think people need to realize that
it's a it's a hormonal treatment it's
going to change the way you think
exactly yes i remember reading the story
where they said that women who are about
to get married should get off birth
control for six weeks and then uh check
to see if they enjoy the smell of their
fiancee yeah because what was happening
was a lot remember that yeah women would
be on birth control they'd be like i'm
going to marry this guy then as soon as
they got married okay let's have a kid
get off birth control and she'd be like
whoa he smells really bad and i don't
want to have kids with him it's like
yeah because the hormonal treatment iran
was changing i'm going to keep going on
this alex jones track plus the birth
control can't be filtered out and is
passed on to a lot of people unknowingly
the bumblebees are going to be involved
here these are
you saying that these female hormones
from the birth control are going in the
water where there are frogs yes yes
thank you we did it and we
did it
but but but it but it's true it's having
a new yorker
exactly it's having a nuclear
neurological effect on so many different
people
and what are the effects well you could
see record low uh record uh infertility
uh we see europe is going down you'll be
infertile and you'll be happy exactly
well there's a big component to this
with limiting uh human growth limiting
people having the ability to have their
own children so there is there's a lot
of the biggest there's so many things
you know i see with this and and you
know like you know people say like oh
jack how'd you go i'm sorry like no i i
mean i was raised catholic my whole
family's catholic both sides all the way
back you know that's how we look at
things and the more and more this is one
of the dangers of transhumanism and joe
allen out there is a great guy who
writes on this you know one of the
biggest dangers of that is that the more
and more you
uh cyber size yourself the more and more
you give yourself your autonomy your
physical self over to your neurological
self over to these machines right the
more you hook yourself up to these
machines to become like a darth vader
type creature then you're cutting
yourself off from any type of spiritual
life you're cutting yourself off from
any kind of transcendent
experiences that you could be having
through prayer through meditation um if
you're more on the secular side but you
know you are not going to be able to do
that why because your own thoughts are
going to be controlled by these
mechanisms there's a reason they go
after your pineal gland i could continue
on this trial now i'm going to stop i
pulled up the source
i pulled up the story from npr and what
they actually say is there's some other
stories saying that the estrogen in the
water is actually less than one percent
is from improperly disposed of
medications what they what npr does say
though is plastics leech bpa yeah into
your water
and it is an estrogenic chemical so it
mimics estrogen don't touch your seeds
so if you're drinking we got these
beautiful glass bottles here this is tim
cast pure this was fantastic i just
finished that double nine stage filter
that's that's that's water right there
baby bias phenol a not all plastic has
it in it but a lot of it did until
recently stay away from seed oils don't
trust uh or does it don't touch receipts
because of the material receipts i heard
about that too that also wrecked your
testimony
my brother talks about so there's the
soy boy thing get it away from me cbs a
lot of conservatives were like the these
hipsters are eating so much soy it's
making them effeminate and
uh so my brother was talking about this
he was like yeah but soy is a
phytoestrogen it's a weaker form of
estrogen so actually the natural
estrogens in your body would be
displaced yeah we started both we
started talking about it and i think
what we actually
what i actually ended up saying was hold
on a minute
if a dude is getting a small amount of
estrogen that's potent but then gets a
massive flood of less potent estrogen
but still more of it
it will have a estrogenic effect on the
man feminizing him and for women
who are getting a larger amount of
stronger estrogen they're now having
that blocked by phytoestrogens displaced
so it's effectively androgynizing men
and women hey speaking of we just got
glass bottles you know in all
seriousness i know huge i mentioned my
mom's watching but huge shout out by the
way to um to my grandmother passed away
in 2012 but she was talking about all
this stuff in the 1990s good for her she
was so far ahead of the curve literally
all the things we just discussed
and you know it used to be one of those
things like okay grandma whatever
and she would go to there wasn't whole
foods at the time but she would go and
she would get organic and she would put
things in tupperware and bring her own
food everywhere she's like i don't want
chemicals i want real food i want
anything messing with that stuff i don't
want the estrogen that's in everything i
don't want the estrogen that's in the
meat by the way because of what they
give factory processed
animals and she was 100 right about so
much of this stuff a hundred percent
right everybody talks about it now
cutting edge and she actually wrote
something
uh before she passed away that i
recreate years ago i recorded like as an
audiobook just to you know she would
give it out at her church and stuff to
people and i was i keep wondering like
will i be incredibly sued by the ftc if
i just go back and re-release that thing
that'd be awesome you know we have so
many farms around here
we uh we took a ride we stopped at this
little little farm stand and the
gentleman there was selling fresh tender
loins from a neighboring farm and it was
clean grass-fed right there in the spot
and he was like you could eat a raw it's
clean meat
and we we cooked it up pretty uh medium
rare
amazing you don't know what you're
getting when you go to these
supermarkets you're getting corn fed
beef and you're getting you know salmon
they die or you know reddish orange
because they're actually gray fish farms
every single one of my grandparents had
a joke and in polish that means just a
plot of land uh that you could farm on
so they would always farm their own food
because in poland a lot of the buildings
it's not big it's like a yeah it's a
small plot but you grow your own fruit
you grow your own vegetables you have a
little farm that's dedicated to you and
there's these little plots outside of
these major buildings uh because
communists just had this kind of
brutalist architecture where they had
these huge
buildings where everyone was just
crammed into and when whenever there was
room they would create these little
plots where people would grow their own
food because during communism there's
not a lot of food so every single one of
my grandparents uh made sure when we
always made their own food when we were
visiting sort of the you know the
posobic um hometown back in
in poland it's near uh it's like an hour
outside of uh krakow and it's near jejo
if you know where that is like i know i
know kind of kind of towards levi's like
towards the border um the valve i should
say for my polish friends out there that
you know you would just you wake up and
you go around town and it's like okay
you know across the street bob's got the
chickens let me get some eggs then you
go down here all right so we can fish
people in open markets selling their
butcher
markets yeah we'll go down yeah yeah no
not markets but uh technically black
markets there's people saying that wet
markets look like like the animals and
there's no things that's definitely not
like black i lived in china black
markets
and then the cousins are there with the
cows and you get fresh milk and then you
just go do that once in the morning and
then that's the food that you eat for
the day and there wasn't this
you know this sort of like very western
modernist idea of i'm gonna go to the
supermarket and then stock up on stuff
for like a week or two weeks you know
the cost coefficient of everything yeah
just you go and there's no such thing as
farm to table because that's just food
yeah there's no difference do you speak
polish no not at all oh okay i mean
you know it's funny though uh once china
takes mandarin who's gonna be better off
that was awesome so i will be able to
what i'm gonna do is my job in the
gulags will be to teach the mandarin
classes to all of you so that we will be
able to communicate with the guard yeah
luke you speak polish but how's that
going to help us when the communists
take over
i don't think i'm going to be around
when that happens
i love that tone you know i love chinese
culture i used to read an accent romance
of the three kingdoms was like a
childhood treasure to me and the heroes
lobe you read the book yeah oh wow wow
yeah video games and everything and it's
i i'm still confused like i know the
republic of china went to taiwan the
government fled basically and now that
than the ccp but
cpc i'm being told and like
there there's so much i want peace
between nations but i also understand
like appeasement like neville
chamberlain appeased hitler gave him the
su dayton land and then hitler invaded
poland it's like should we have appeased
hitler in the early days
it wasn't like that it was russia and
germany that yeah and then invaded
poland they made a pact
from the from the left and the right so
september 1st was germany september 17th
1939 was russia yeah and the polish
people said screw it we're still going
to fight both of you even though we're
going to lose we're still going to fight
if there's any diplomatic route between
the chinese people and the american
people i i'm always well there certainly
is
in so the chinese people you'd say la
bashing which is known as it's the old
hundred names because you know that's
sort of like the hundred surnames of
china and there's a difference between
the la baishing and the party so the
party's the ccp and if you actually
calculate the numbers you know we always
say the one percent in the u.s it's
actually less than one percent of the
1.4 billion population of china is a
member of the party so being a member of
the party what they'll do is they co-opt
right so as you're on your way up uh
china it's a very mer it's a very
meritorious society so if you're doing
well in school if you're doing well in
business if you're seen as someone who's
notable in any one of these fields what
they'll do is at some point the party
comes up to you and offers you
membership and then being a member of
the party becomes your way to gain
access to greater capital to greater
funds to greater networking so in that
way they're able to maintain control
over all these industries but then of
course they've also got eyesight into
what exactly you're doing so every
you know prior to social media and
technological surveillance
right they would just assign somebody
they'd assign a guy so you'd have a
minder for your work every work unit
would have a party member every
apartment block would have a party
member and then they would be keeping
track who's getting married who's having
kids uh who's getting divorced who died
who you know who's moving who's going
here and there so they have this mass
surveillance network within the country
writ large they don't even need the
technology for that and that still
continues to this day the la baijing are
like old family names the old families
yeah like the lou family the the shoe
family like just those names you hear
x-u uh l-i-u yeah so it's it's like
saying the hoi polloi or saying you know
the the proletariat or the deplorables
you know in the u.s it's just saying
like the the little guys are they is
there like against the cp ccp oh they're
underneath they're underneath the ccp do
they do the last name first in china
they do so like xi jinping she would be
the family name oh okay so his actual
name is people refer to him as she so
chairman g right but his name is
actually shin ping jinping jinping yeah
so his given i mean you wouldn't they
don't really
you know you don't really address
somebody by their first name like the
way we do in the u.s unless you're with
other members of their families yeah
it's like it's very familiar to do that
like i i wouldn't do that and there's
like another used to do that back in my
neighborhood just refer to people by
their last names we do that military too
yeah yeah isn't there like you give
people like a common like a common name
if you know him pretty well like kong
ming would be choking
uh they called him kong ming right
people that know him why what kind of
name young is a little bit different
because
is his last name but it's very very rare
to have a double syllable last name in
china but he actually had one that guy
was smart huh very smart very story of
him sitting on the on the wall playing
the loot with the doors open can you
tell the story do you know it i don't
know the whole story off the top of my
head but you know yeah he was uh in
general they were basically outnumbered
and being invaded by i don't remember
who xiao don i hope is the person that
was doing i don't remember some some
general under south south i think was
coming to invade the city and
they just opened the gates and uh
went up and sat there and played his uh
what was it a loot he played
and they came there and they saw him and
they were like uh this is a trap
right so they turned this huge army and
they yeah they retreated
the door he opened the gates and he set
up on the wall just playing and they
were like no
all right
we have to you know it's like it reminds
me of uh um the dude from uh who is the
guy in princess bride
uh who was right wesley no the smart guy
not pheasant oh
i can't remember what's the name
no no the smart guy who was like
inconceivable yeah that's wallace sean
what's the characters now i don't know
let's find out how could i not remember
i thought was his name no that's the
giant that's that's the giant okay yeah
was that it yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah so this reminds me of
like once where it actually worked out
you know when when when you go liang
sits on the wall and right right it's
like
i know that you know that i know yeah
exactly and then he ends up winning out
he was constantly and with this guy c
mcgee you know is that how you pronounce
his name south south advisor and there
was this constant like battle of
checkers between the two of them are
chess throughout the years it was it's
an incredible in the three kingdoms is
incredible yeah that's actually salto is
actually they you've um you know we have
the phrase in english of um you know
speak of the devil and he shall appear
well in chinese they have ish
so it's like actually like a similar you
know if you speak of south south south
shall appear that's wild yes because
it's like the hero in the story i don't
wanna i mean it's hard to spoil a 600
year old novel but
basically the heroes in my opinion lose
they don't succeed which is the sad part
it's like a tragic history
but it's just a beautiful story of
brotherhood someone actually said ian
luke and tim you're like lupe guanyu and
jang fei i'm like these are like what
did you just call me
i'm not sure which one you are maybe one
you i'm not sure
it's but it's like the three heroes
basically that are up against all odds
i love that do you ever read uh journey
the west no that one's great too the
monkey king oh so you got that's that's
the next one that's your homework next
time you've come back
i want to see it
thank you
fezig was the giant buzzing was giant
okay that was that was andre the giant
yep and then vasini was they're remaking
it yeah oh no
no see my favorite thing about princess
bride is that it like it's actually kind
of low budget when you think of it like
when they're on that that night scene at
sea you can tell it's like like a pool
like an indoor pool that's just like the
lights turned off but i like that i like
that ass and the you know the rats of
unusual size or like rodents of usual
size they're just like like obviously
like really really poorly made puppets
what's the hero the west this novel
you're talking about monkey king monkey
king uh-huh what's that about
uh it's it's kind of like they steal a
giant gorilla and bring him to new york
and he climbs a building oh so you've
read it
what are suicide it's this idea that you
know
going to the west and and going to the
western china of course it's like going
out to the desert but that you sort of
like you you find yourself you find uh
you're faced with your own fears you're
faced with your own foibles your own
shortcomings as a person but then to
seek wisdom you need to face yourself
cool yeah so these are considered some
of the cl and the other ones dream of
red chambers so these are considered the
three great classics of china you know
the movie hero
apparently there was a controversy
around this it's a jet li and he's
trying to preserve the word or something
well so jeff was banned in china though
well so no no no no hero no no no hero
was like funded by the ccp oh really
yeah no hero is a super pro ccp um
uh movie and i'll spoil the heck out of
that one so in hiro
it's kind of like star wars right so
you've got an empire and you've got
rebels it's just ancient china instead
of the future excuse me a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away but with the
difference being that at the end luke
skywalker decides to murder his friends
and join the emperor
and basically you're told that's sort of
like the you know the great dane iman of
the film at the climax when he's about
to kill the emperor the emperor says
don't you understand the only way that
china can survive is if we have an
empire and so the emperor must win you
must turn your back on the rebels and he
said and then gently becomes a hero by
turning his back on his friends i gotta
say it would be really awesome if you
know at the end of the return of the
jedi
vader's like join the dark side and luke
is like all right yes yeah and or or if
he was like don't you see what will
happen the war will wars will break out
the fighting everything you've witnessed
and luke is like he's right
people are just bad and then he joins
the emperor and then he just starts he
like then you see luke wearing the dark
cloak and he goes up to han and he's
like hey what happened
just walked up to leia
cuts her head off that would have been
way better than whatever it is they made
after this seriously i don't even know
what they made after those
don't exist my issues with with chinese
lore is the is the empire of it like
even lube who's one of my heroes of all
time was there to restore the emperor
well see this is the thing right china
has always been a series of empires and
this goes back to confucianism which is
it's it's hierarchical
it's you know the father you know the
children must give uh homage to the
father the father must give homage to
the local leader the local leader must
give homage to the regional leader the
provincial leader and then eventually
all the way up to the empire so this has
been the way the ccp has structured
itself is actually very traditional in
chinese society in in certain ways when
you look at it in terms of this
hierarchy and many people looked at this
and said that china is essentially just
the ccp is just the latest dynasty it's
not necessarily as familial as the
former dynasties were but it's a dynasty
in many aspects
you